donc voila moi j'ai en fait je vais vous
parler de commencer alité c'est à dire
le partage de la nourriture et donc les
changes est en fait moi je dis souvent
vive le sport ce qui a rien à voir avec
moi mais le sport c'est le champignon
parce que en fait on est sur un sol et
sur ceux dans ce sol dans les 5 cm 10 cm
qui sont en tout nous il y à 90% des
êtres qui sont sur la terre et il se
trouve que maintenant nous nous rendons
compte que les êtres de ce sol sont
aussi les êtres qui sont qui nous forme
nous donc voilà nous sommes des buttes
sol en fait en haut vous avez la partie
qui vit avec l'air en dessous vous avez
la partie qui vit sans heurts et au
milieu vous avez ce parti qui vit avec
leur 101 sont des êtres en fait qu'ils
sont qui vivent très bien avec l'air
mais qui peuvent tout à fait s'en passer
alors le problème c'est que ces êtres là
la plupart du temps ce sont des êtres
qui sont à ces pathogènes
alors j'ai essayé pas vous déprimez mais
c'est juste pour alerter
parce que souvent on ne pense que tout
ce qui a de mauvaises les herbicides la
chimie tout ça dans la nourriture et on
oublie bien souvent que la bonne
nourriture commence par les bonnes
pratiques agricoles et les bonnes
pratiques de transformation donc voilà
c'est tout césaire tous ces êtres qui
sont dans le sol alors c'est ce qu'on
connaît généralement mais en fait le ver
de terre
c'est le grand prédateur est en réalité
la grande majorité de ces êtres là et
bien cela et c'est être là sont aussi
dans notre dans notre tube digestif
parce qu'en fait le sol c'est exactement
la même chose qu'un tube digestif
tout ce qui tombe tout ce qui vit sur la
planète tout ce qui tombe dessus
stinat être digérée et la bouche à
l'estomac
nous avons des bactéries qui vivent avec
l'air après nous avons les bactéries
intermédiaires et en dessous nous avons
les bactéries qui sont vraiment les
arcades où les bactéries qui vivent sans
heurts alors imaginez ça ne vous
viendrait pas à l'esprit d'inverser les
choses comme on fait avec la terre de la
labourer parce que en fait quand on
retourne la terre est bien ce qui est au
dessus va en dessous vie sans air tout
d'un coup 100 m eur et ce qui est en
dessous vie au soleil sous tous crêpes
et donc voilà c'est exactement la même
chose ici dans notre tube digestif et
chaque chose à sa place
alors ici commence le problème c'est à
dire que exactement comme dans un champ
labouré s'est tout d'un coup les plantes
qui sont du champ labouré ce ruisseau
rempli en fait des êtres qui sont donc
ces bactéries intermédiaires qui sont
celles des sols qui restent et elle
rentre dans la personne qui se nourrit
et elle crée des déséquilibres de de
flore intestinale et de vie ces
bactéries prennent le dessus et donc le
in il manque sept partis qui étaient les
bactéries aérobies que celle qui leva et
claire pour digérer et donc les parties
donc comme c'est mal digérée après ceux
qui suivent qui font leur boulot après
les premières et bien le se retrouve
avec des gros morceaux et elles font
passer ces gros morceau tant qu'elles
peuvent à travers les rois intestinale
alors chez l'homme chez nous chez
l'adulte
ça va encore parce que bon on aura un
petit stress une petite fatigue on va
avoir une petite sieste après après le
déjeuner mais chez l'enfant c'est pas du
tout ça chez l'enfant il va réagir par
de la violence alors première alerte la
chose qu'on a on oublie de dire voilà en
violon temps le sol en labourant en
empêchant
son cycle naturel de digestion ces
bactéries aérobies que celles qui
vivaient avec l'air en surface
si elles ne sont plus là et bien là
nourriture qui sera produit là dessus
sur ce sol provoquent la violence chez
nos enfants
il ya un professeur professeur berthet
qui est fait donc des grandes recherches
là dessus et qui a fait donc le profil
bactérien d'un sol qui est après
exactement la même chose que le profil
bactérien de la vache et qui devient
bactérien de l'homme qui boit le lait de
la vache
voilà alors après c'est une deuxième
chose
les bactéries le sol on pense toujours
que c'est un une choses inertes en fait
est en réalité tout est géré par les
bactéries
si l'eau rentre dans le sol c'est parce
qu'il y à sa demande pas du tout et
d'une manière mécanique c'est parce que
il y à des échanges entre bactérien et
puis dans un mètre cube de sol
il y a environ 70 kg en europe en tout
cas de fer et d'aluminium
ces bactéries elle gère l'état ionique
c'est à dire la stabilité ionique de ces
de ces métaux et si ces bactéries
n'existe plus et s'il n existe plus il y
a une équation très simple plan physique
qui fait que ces métaux l'aluminium se
transforme en alumine hic le faire
henrion ferrique le nitrate en niant
nitrites et alors là commencent les
problèmes parce que ce sont des
décisions beaucoup plus qu'ils ont une
capacité détourner les électrons
beaucoup plus forte et donc le résultat
c'est la dégénérescence des maladies de
dégénérescence nerveuse
là j'ai commencé le sérieusement à vous
déprimer mais l'objectif c'est pas ça
parce que en fait si nous on arrive à
manger plein de choses et si on est là
ici encore c'est qu'il y a quand même
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de réseaux
les deux solutions sur cette planète et
un les fleurs les fleurs sauvages
et deux les champignons donc c'est ce
que je vais vous montrer
donc ça ce sont des champignons qui sont
des champignons qui sont aussi
médicinaux et en fait il y a une chose
sont des plantes voilà la plante a fait
une chose qui est une invention il ya
220 millions 220 millions d'années
excusez moi elle a inventé une chose qui
est la graine invention extraordinaire
parce qu'elle choisit le moment et le
lieu où elle va éclore elle choisit le
bon moment
elle attend elle rentre en dormance et
quand les conditions répond à son adn et
les conditions climatiques et du sun
réponde à son adn elle décide de germer
alors vous prenez ce principe et vous
leur tournée et ça veut dire que si vous
rencontrez une plante sauvage un papa
plantaire et bien ça veut dire que l
vous indique les conditions de l'endroit
où elle est née et donc l'atlante
devient indicatrices alors c'est
fantastique parce que si la plante vous
indique les conditions du sol elle vous
indique aussi les endroits les
pollutions et donc à partir de ce moment
là eh bien on sait on te lire et prendre
ces nourritures d'une manière totalement
sauf sans son problème
voilà et donc toutes ces graines et avec
les plantes des plantes bio indicatrices
il est une deuxième chose
les champignons alors les champignons
s'apprêterait cette spectaculaire
en 1998 il y avait en oregon un parc
national qui s'est monté un petit peu et
pour attirer les touristes ils ont un
peu aménagés nettoyer les arbres et
construit des routes et à l'inauguration
un mois après deux mois après ils
reviennent ils font le tour du parc il
peut enfin et c'est tellement grand et
puis sur les plaines il se rend compte
que la route a été digérée alors là et
se sont rendus compte qu'en fait la
plaine qu'il traversait cette plaine l'a
donc 5
km de long 2 km de large sur quatre
mètres d'épaisseur
trente-deux mille tonnes un être le plus
gros être du monde
un champignon une arme hilaire qui a
environ 8000 ans voilà ça c'est le
spectaculaire ça c'est le chant pinault
qui digère qui est en train de gérer la
clairière qui est en train de gérer la
vie de la forêt en fait mais à côté de
ça le rôle fondamental de champignons
donc ça c'est la meilleure et l'art
millaire la nuit et lumineuse ça ne
s'est pas un trucage donc voilà le rôle
fondamental du sang du champignon c'est
de se lier avec la plante depuis l'année
dernière exactement depuis le 4 août
2015 il y a à peu près 15 universités 27
chercheurs de sept pays différents qui
se sont alliées ensemble pour faire une
publication et qui ont démontré que la
première algues le premier végétal qui
soit sorti de l'eau pour créer une
plante s'est allié avec un champignon
donc depuis un peu moins d'un an
la définition d'une plante c'est un
végétal qui s'est allié un champignon
les autres plantes sont des plantes
créée par l'homme de laboratoire qui
n'existe pas sur terre voilà alors le
champignon qu'est-ce qui fait avec la
plante et bien c'est le cuisinier de la
plante
il va chercher sa nourriture son nom et
tout ça pourquoi parce qu'une plante une
racine le radis salsa pouce de dominer
mais par par jour un champignon
le corps du champion c'est à dire son
mycélium c'est 2 cm par jour et de ça de
manière complètement exponentielle
repartant avec les embranchements et
tout ça et ça va tellement vite qu'on
peut on peut le voir là c'est une
expérience qui a été fait donc comme 87
par un japonais qui avait mis ce qu'ils
ont des idées très intéressantes
ils ont mis la côte est un sport 2000
champignons et dans l'autre côté un
grain d'orge maltée donc qu'ils sont
bien de sucre et le champignon à tous
dans un labyrinthe et le champignon est
allé directement chercher le sucre donc
super efficace et il y a une chose aussi
c'est que il va pas bon alors la
différence du champignon avec nous parce
qu'en fait le champignon a commencé
exactement sur la même branche dans
l'évolution que l'homme est en fait la
différence du champignon avec nous c'est
quelqu'un qui est assorti qui a retourné
ses tripes dire que nous on a tous le
snow partie de sal nos éléments à
l'intérieur
dans notre système digestif et lui en
fait d'être digérés à l'extérieur et va
projeter ces enzymes et va céder des
autres bactéries pour digérer et il va
tellement vite que là vous voyez un
champignon qui s'est développée pour
attraper un verre ça c'est le petit le
petit filaments c'est le filament du
champignon qui va attraper une méthode
qui est en train d'attaquer un plant de
tomate
voilà et après le champignon yves a
véhiculé dans son filaments les
nourritures qui l'a transformé en
nanoparticules à la vitesse de
l'électricité dans l'eau c'est-à-dire
226 milles kilomètres heure et faire des
kilomètres comme ça et à tel point que
healy à l'année dernière aussi
il ya des étudiants chiliens qui ont
inventé un chargeur pourtant chargé leur
portable qu'il plante directement dans
le sol au niveau des racines et qui
charge d'un portable en 6 heures et ça
ça c'est pas un gadget
ça c'est le big bang permanent parce que
à 1953 il y à un type stade les 1001 un
chercheur physicien extraordinaire qui a
fait une bulle où il a recréé
l'atmosphère de la terre avant la vie
avec une atmosphère ultra pauvres il y
avait des éléments inerte et il a fait
passer de dans un arc électrique
voilà ça c'est lui 87
et vous veillez l'arc électrique et
alors il n'a pas créé ce frankenstein
il a créé des acides aminés les acides
aminés ce sont les briques fondamentales
avec lequel on forme d'abord notre adn
et toutes les protéines tous les enzymes
on utilise dans la vie voilà et donc ça
vous dit rien cette expérience une
atmosphère pauvres avec des
nanoparticules qu'ils passent et des
courants électriques
et bien c'est un champignon alors il
était il est maintenant prouvé que dans
un champ labouré dans un champ où il n'y
a plus de mycorhizes où tout a été
anéantie par le roundup et tout ça il y
a il n'y a plus de lait les plantes sont
en carence des acides aminés alors nous
pour nous c'est très important parce que
nous avons 22 acides aminés kinuko rue
qui nous cours si tu es sur ces 22 il y
en a neuf qui sont essentiels alors
troisième alerte pour les bonnes
pratiques
c'est que un champ labouré qui n'a plus
de maîtrise ne prétend carence d'acides
aminés essentiels
ces acides aminés essentiels comme on
les produit pas on doit aller chercher
ailleurs
alors les végétariens qui se nourrissent
uniquement de plantes qui vont acheter
au supermarché son temps 15
et nous qui ne sommes pas des gîtes moi
je suis pas végétarien je vais compenser
sa carence en mangeant une vache ou un
poisson qui aura mangé des plantes
sauvages turin manger de l'herbe qui
aurait mangé des algues donc voilà hyper
important voilà une des raisons que
aucun nutritionniste vous dira mais en
biologie on voit alors vive le sport
parce que c'est le sauvage dont nous
avons besoin et il faut l'une des choses
vraies et un autre tabou je sais pas
quand on dit ça on dit toujours 11 oui
avec la montée de la mer on aura plus
rien pour sauver la planète 9 milliards
de personnes amours impossibles à
nourrir eh bien non dans dans les bords
de mer désolé pour la pub mais avec
cette photo tout à l'heure pour la main
voilà tout ça c'est les marais salants
et bien tout ça c'est à manger et non
seulement c'est à manger voilà je vous
ai fassois plus et ça c'est un triplex
donc ce sont des amarantes essais dont
la plupart les amarantes à celle oms a
dit que c'était la plante qui avait
autant de protéines que la viande de
boeuf et il y a deux fois plus de
calcium que dans le meilleur délai qui
n'existe plus d'ailleurs et qui est
assimilable immédiatement et en plus de
ça on ya deux ans au mois d'août il ya
vu un colloque cambridge university avec
tous les chercheurs qui font la
recherche sur le cerveau et quelques
nutritionniste et on a démontré et
surtout des paléontologues et on a
démontré que 20 on a monté une hypothèse
selon laquelle parmi homo erectus
il y a trois quatre cinq tribus connu
près tout ce qui se passe en deux dans
nos connaissances au départ et qui ont
évolué sur les bords de mer dans des
endroits protégés et ils ont mangé
pendant un million d'années des plantes
et des choses de la mer et qu'est ce
qu'il ya là dedans via glode il ya des
antioxydants spécifique au cerveau et
ils ont doublé leurs capacités
cérébrales et homo sapiens est né voilà
l'hypothèse qu'on a mis donc hyper
important hélas condensats l'itc
vraiment la base de la vie parce que
cette liaison avec les champignons et
les plantes
eh bien c'est ce qui a fait toutes les
évolutions aujourd'hui le top de
l'évolution de la plante
c'est une orchidée qui vivent au delà en
haut de l'arbre eh bien elle n'est pas
en haut de l'arbre
elle est en liaison avec le sol à
travers des champignons et des bactéries
qui font le lien qui est lui remonté
j'ai fait des ddd cosmétiques à base
d'orchidées tout ça pour des grands
groupes est en réalité j'ai été très
peiné parce que lorsqu'il y avait que je
voulais elle était classée interdite
c'est impossible
de l'avoir et je me suis maintenant
allons étudier le champignon qui vit
avec elle et je me suis rendu compte que
le principe actif qu'il était demandé
moi je suis contre le principe actif
parce que c'est vraiment réduit vraiment
la pensée tout est bon dans la plante
mais là ils vont me demande le principe
actif est donc je vais le chercher dans
le champignon est donc un champignon sa
puissante cinq jours en cinq jours j'ai
mon mycélium et j'ai pas besoin de faire
partir ce magnifique orchidée et en fait
là je vous ai montré les tomates c'est
exactement la même chose les tomates la
tomate une soirée assez toutes les
sauces et les pommes de terre tout ça ça
décidé de sortir de la terre des tomates
de pleine terre
ça n'a aucun intérêt la tomate de pleine
terre elle poussera elle va donner de
saint-quentin fin de la saison alors
produit peut-être centaine de tentes 500
kg de tomates une tomate hors sol cette
fin de la saison ses 30 mètres de long
et sera plus un produit plusieurs tonnes
de temps être le problème c'est que ces
gens qui font la tomb raider sol dans
des serres de béton ils font ça sur de
la laine de roche et ils disent pas que
la laine de roche c'est du silicate
d'aluminium qui font dans la tomate et
donc qui produisent des alumines it et
donc qui dit donc si vous mangez de la
tomate comme ça moi j'ai conseillé les
gens là hop et au machin et il faut
surtout enlever toutes les graines parce
que sinon c'est à zain heures direct ça
il faut bien vous le dire quatrième à l'
alerte sa personne le dire et donc mais
si ils mettaient des champignons hors
sol et ils créeraient un lien avec le
sol et bien leur problème serait résolu
le thomas tu aurais dû goût et elle
aurait des nutriments
ça c'est bon après il faut faire de la
biologie donc et et donc il ya une chose
absolument folle
c'est à dire que vous savez depuis 1992
une une station orbitale qui tourne
autour de nous et l'année dernière il ya
80 astronautes qui sont allés depuis 90
et bien l'année dernière ils sont d'une
compte qu'il y avait un tas de bactéries
et tout ça et tout d'un coup halle
les gérants se sont dit mais attention
ces excès c'est horrible on va tuer tous
nos astres
tout ça est donc ils ont voulu passer au
karcher vraiment et donc mettre des
antibiotiques à fond et tout à coup il
ya un biologiste qui s'est dit à la nasa
il dit d'être attention et s'il y en a
une qui résiste le petit étudiant qui
diane astronautes qui n'a jamais touché
la terre de sa vie et bien il va crever
si vous mettez là dedans et bien pour la
première fois ils ont pas eu le réflexe
hygiéniste et ils ont laissé faire c'est
incroyable tout d'un coup on a remis
pasteur en en cause et donc toute cette
atmosphère qui se crée tout cette vie
qui s'est créé cette commensalité qui
s'est créé là dans l'espace c'était des
petits bouts de terres qui ont été
apportées par les astronautes
voilà je vous remercie